every summer towering storm clouds
gathered over the central United States
summer storms here have some of the most
intense rain lightning and winds in the
world we've long known that these storms
pose a threat to people on the ground
now some scientists fear they could also
be threatening Earth's ozone layer by
moving water and pollutants high into
the sky into a layer of the atmosphere
that some scientists call the overworld
it's a controversial idea now NASA has
funded a research project to see if it
might be right the ozone layer protects
us from harmful ultraviolet radiation
which can cause skin cancer and other
health problems much of the ozone is
found in the lower stratosphere that's
the cold dry layer of the atmosphere
that begins some 14 kilometers or nearly
nine miles up in the 1980s researchers
showed that industrial chemicals that
reach the stratosphere for creating a
hole in the ozone layer over the South
Pole that prompted nations to reach an
agreement called the Montreal Protocol
that phased out some of the worst ozone
destroyers the Montreal Protocol has
reduced the concentrations of these
chemicals in the atmosphere which is
helping heal the stratospheric ozone
hole but now researchers fear there's a
new threat to the ozone layer this time
it's far from the polar regions over
North America's stormy and Great Plains
normally storms don't affect the
stratosphere but researchers suspect
some towering storms called
overshoots can leave a mark by injecting
water and pollutants into the overworld
there the extra moisture and chemicals
help catalyze reactions that destroy
ozone to see if there's evidence for
that idea NASA will send a special
research jet high into the atmosphere
above the US over the next few years the
jet called in the er-2
is a modified version of the military's
u-2 spy plane that can reach more than
20,000 meters or about 70,000 feet
the er-2 will fly into areas where
overshoots have just passed by and use
its instruments to sniff the air for
water vapor and chemicals it will also
measure air temperatures because even
slightly colder temperatures can greatly
speed up ozone destruction overall the
goal is to see if the storms could be
helping create the right conditions for
ozone destruction it'll be years before
the scientists have solid results and to
be sure so far there's no evidence that
the ozone layers getting thinner over
the US but some scientists worried that
climate change could change that a
warming earth is expected to make the
atmosphere wetter and overshoots more
common already they've discovered that
overshoots over the US occur more often
than once thought scientists used to
think there were just a few overshoots
each year in reality there are some
45,000 overshoots storms over the
central u.s. each year so researchers
are moving to study these storms now to
get an early warning of any future
problems especially because more than
100 million people living across the
central United States depend on the
ozone layer for protection
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]